[Musique]
pour faire cette crème glacée j'ai une
tasse écart de lait écrémé et j'ajoute
une demi tasse de lait évaporé les
années passent mais les outils de
cuisine restent
encore leur place sur le marché l'offre
d'aujourd'hui est un très grand en
magasin Vincent Lavoie enseignant en
pâtisserie à l'ITHQ nous a aidé à
dénicher les bonnes tasses à mesurer
nous en avons testé 12 pour ingrédients
secs et 12 pour ingrédients liquides les
prix varient entre 3 et 50 dollars et la
qualité aussi dans l'ensemble on trouve
principalement le vert le plastique on
trouve aussi un peu de stainless mais le
standless est plutôt un secteur
professionnel d'abord notre expert a
vérifié le calibrage c'est-à-dire la
précision des mesures indiquées
nous on a travaillé avec l'eau l'eau a
un poids qui est fixe avec la balance de
précision j'ai fait trois mesures par la
suite j'ai pris une moyenne de tout ça
pour pouvoir nous permettre d'avoir des
pourcentages de marge d'erreur donc on a
on a regardé à partir de 5% ça nous
paraît convenable quand la marche
d'erreur dépasse les 10%, l'élimination
commence rapidement
pour tester les tasses liquides nous
avons opté pour le format deux tasses ou
500 millilitres celle en vert rime
souvent avec solidité mais pas toute
Ricardo c'est du vert aussi ça c'est un
verre qui est fin c'est à peu près le
même stress que nettoyer un verre à vin
là imaginez ça dans le lave-vaisselle
c'est un beau modèle mais
c'est fragile bien lire la mesure c'est
capital je vois ici on a des grandes
lignes qui sont larges avec les mesures
qui sont bien alignées alors que si je
regarde ici les mesures sont au centre
il y a tellement de lignes que c'est
facile de s'y perdre
ces modèles on peut également effectuer
les mesures par le haut on voit que
c'est gradué sur le côté mais c'est
également gradué sur le haut je vois
très bien le la quantité que je vais
verser alors qu'ici regardez la
différence
c'est dans l'autre sens exactement il
faut la retourner comme ça ce qui fait
que le mouvement le mouvement est un
petit peu moins naturel attention au
design de tasse trop effilées et graduée
à la limite de la tasse comme c'est très
fin et très long c'est difficile de se
déplacer là évidemment on va pas aller
faire du jogging ou de la danse en ligne
avec notre tasse mais on veut ensuite
une bonne prise en main si je regarde ce
modèle premièrement le plastique est de
mauvaise qualité faut savoir que plus il
y a de poids plus la poignée devient
molle peut un certain point la poignée
va simplement plier regardez par exemple
ce modèle-ci vous pouvez le prendre en
main vous allez voir ça fait toute la
longueur de la main alors qu'ici ben
j'avoue moi j'ai une grosse main là mais
c'est là ici ça nous arrive à peu près
aux trois quarts de la main donc c'est
un peu moins confortable maintenant
est-ce que c'est un atout ou pas
potentiellement son travail avec des
ingrédients chauds on veut une poignée
pour que ça soit solide pour éviter les
risques de brûlures en plus c'est
relativement mou aussi là pour le
déversement c'est difficile c'est un peu
un gadget pour moi alors catégorie tasse
liquide les nommé son cambro Oxo et
pyrex mon choix premier c'est le modèle
pyrex dans la transpirex toutes les
indications sont là on a des grandes
lignes des gros caractères de l'espace
entre les informations
tous modèles puis on aurait pu en
acheter encore plus que ça mais c'est
beau ça fait plein de couleurs
oui pour les ingrédients secs mais
également pour tout ce qui est collant
et tout ce qui est épais donc
borderrachide miel crème sur comme les
tasses à mesurer sèches n'ont pas de
rebord ça nous permet d'avoir des
mesures qui sont fixes c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir racler la surface pour
avoir des recettes qui sont standards si
on pense justement au modèle en
standless si on essaie de racler sa cote
comme celui-ci
c'est le cas de plusieurs modèles dont
le starfrites qui étonne tellement est
diffère des autres j'ai comme
l'impression juste à le manipulant que
ça se peut que ça casse faut comprendre
que ce genre de modèle c'est uniquement
utile pour le sucre la farine imaginez
la mélasse là dedans
j'aime pas la forme non exactement la
forme est pas ronde c'est gadget
vraiment éviter
ça c'est le modèle de KitchenAid c'est
un modèle que j'ai bien apprécié c'est
l'unique modèle qui est rond avec la
forme ronde ça nous permet vraiment de
corner puis d'aller chercher tous nos
ingrédients donc pas de perte la
stabilité c'est très important aussi
donc faut savoir que avec le modèle de
Oxo tous les modèles sont stables on
voyez-vous ça reste droit comme ça donc
si je pense au 8e de tas voilà c'est ça
qui arrive la problématique c'est très
souvent le huitième de tasse le quart de
tasse donc la cavité avec le manche donc
ça fait ça fait un poids ça va tomber
sur le côté pour la lecture des mesures
on trouve l'imprimé le relief et la
gravure le test du tampon a récurer et
sans équivoque au betty est déjà disparu
longtemps j'ai frotté uniquement le
Betty mais
j'imagine que dans pas long on va perdre
les mesures
c'est quoi ça c'est plastique aussi
c'est un mélange de fibre de blé donc
c'est un modèle qu'on vend écho donc
c'est un alliage avec de la fibre de blé
ça c'est intéressant comme modèle non
déjà pouvez-vous m'indiquer quelle est
la mesure ici il y a un quart de temps
exactement mais la lecture est difficile
la solidité des manches est parfois
décevante pour ce qui est de la
cassonade la plupart du temps on parle
d'une cassonade qui est bien passée si
j'essaie d'aller chercher directement
comme ça qu'est-ce qui arrive
maintenant c'est fragile catégorie tasse
pour ingrédients secs les nommés sont
les deux modèles de Oxo et la ronde de
KitchenAid ces trois modèles me plaisent
beaucoup mon préféré c'est le modèle
doxo je trouve très bien d'avoir un
moulage dans une seule pièce encore une
fois ça facilite le raclage c'est un
modèle en inox aussi donc c'est à dire
qu'il va rester beau à travers les
années donc pour moi c'est vraiment une
belle option